Hearts their desires became tainted
now they can't be naked in the presence
of the other they have to be clothed now
here's where I say the Demonic realm
wants to then reverse this what do I
mean what did God do genesis
3:21 what did God do God bless you B
then Yahweh God made garments of skin
for Adam and his wife and he clothed
them notice now after sin
now after corruption has entered the
world now God says you will be clothed
and you won't walk around in front of
each other
naked
right but what did the demons do they
want to reverse and undo what God does
so what do they
do what do they have that man do have
him walk around
naked why cuz they want to destroy all
that God has done and they want to
pervert the ways of God so God says
you're clothed they say no we're going
to make you naked and
ashamed is it sinking in what the
Demonic realm is all about what do
demons and Satan want to do they want to
destroy you and cause you to against
God's standard because they know God
loves you and desires what's best for
you and if you do what God tells you to
do that's best for you and they want to
stop that from
you all right so we got all that right
so this man no power on Earth could
chain him up bind him up he's walking in
the tombs signifying death demons only
inhabit the
dead right he's walking in desert desert
places demons only inhabit waterless
places because having no water and
living in the tombs means you're
spiritually dead therefore you don't
have the Holy Spirit the Water of Life
to make you alive making a
connection but now here's where you're
going to see the glory of Jesus Christ
here you're going to see the glory of
Jesus
Christ notice right here Luke 8:28
here's where you're going to see the
glory of Jesus Christ watch here now
seeing Jesus he cried out and fell
before him said in loud voice what do I
have to do with you J son of the most
high God I beg you do not torment me
notice that no one could constrain him
on Earth chains could not constrain him
shackles could not constrain him
right no one was powerful enough to
constrain him Jesus without saying a
word or lifting his
finger the demons recognize him are
shaking and troubling with fear and wh
hor and Terror just at his presence what
does that tell you about
Jesus what does that tell you about
Jesus if no power on Earth could
constrain these
demons and they feared no
one and yet from afar they already
recognized who he was knew he was and
ran bowing Down In Worship trembling
with fear and and Terror knowing
they're utterly powerless against him
and he could torment them at will what
does that tell you about the glory of
Jesus and another
thing they knew who he is already but
now watch this and its cultural con get
any good commentary this how I learned
this and they'll tell you for had
commanded the unclean Spirit to come out
of the man for it seized him many times
and he was bound with chains and
shackles being kept under guard and it
breaking his bonds he was driven by
demon into the desolate regions now
notice and Jesus asked him what is your
name and he said Legion for many demons
had entered him now you know why this is
shocking and ask any Exorcist in its
cultural context this was mind-blowing
what Jesus is doing you
ready even exist will confirm this and I
learned this because I asked someone and
I saw it in a
commentary part and parcel of
controlling the demon is to get him to
confess his name to get the name of the
demon why do you think Exorcist will
tell you when they pray they demand the
demon to tell them him his name because
it is believed that if someone knows
your name they can use your name to
control and manipulate you now you here
here's why this is astonishing they knew
who Jesus was and knew him by name and
they had no control over him and they
were utterly powerless but Jesus asks
their name to show he doesn't need to
know their name to control them whether
the name is given or not they're still
powerless against them and he can
destroy them at will with
ease you with me
there you understand if you understand
historical cultural context this in
itself shows that Jesus is no ordinary
man there are already afraid of him they
already know who he is and they are
trembling with fear and horror and Dread
and they know he can torment them
torture them and they're utterly
powerless against him and they know he
is but Jesus nonchalantly says what is
your name now why is he asking what is
your name because again this is a way of
the gospel writer signifying you see how
much power Jesus has he can already
control the demon and the demons already
trembling before him even before they
give him his name their name his and
them okay but I'm going to take it a
step further Mark tells us they actually
worshiped
Jesus they actually worshiped him so I'm
going to bring in the parallel passages
Mark 5
is the parallel right in Matthew 8 Mark
5 the parallel this story is found in
Mark 5 Matthew 8 and I'm going to tie
them all in let's go to Mark 5 Mark 5
six to 7 but I'm going to look a little
earlier and later into it right watch
nuggets that are there we don't see then
they came to the other side of the sea
and to the region of the gines when he
got out of the boat immediately a man
from the tombs with an unclean Spirit
met him so notice comes out of the tombs
he's dead he came out of the Tomb the
grave he's
dead who had his dwelling on the tombs
and no one is able to bind him anymore
see no human power could control him you
seeing that because he had often been
bound with shackles and chains let me
change the translation because I'm going
show you the Greek word does mean
worship but sadly some translations do
not say worship even though it's a Greek
word for worship and it should be
rendered as worship okay watch here
immediately there met him a man Tob man
with an unclean Spirit who had his
dwelling among the tombs no one could
bind him no power on Earth not even with
chains because he had often been bound
with shackle chains and the chains had
been pulled apart from by him shackles
broken in pieces neither could anyone
tame him what does that tell you about
Jesus what what does that tell you about
Jesus
Focus everyone please don't distract
folks exactly you can only do in the
name of Jesus right if no man on Earth
could tame him control him no Chains No
shackles how can Jesus be a mere
man how can Jesus be a mere
man exactly The Exodus will tell them go
where Jes Jesus tells you to go now
watch how deep it
gets all right watch how deep it gets
and always night and day he was in the
mountains and tombs crying out and
cutting himself with stones so God wants
to heal you and make you whole demons
want to harm you even
physically demons want to destroy you
psychologically emotionally and
physically which is why they will tempt
you to get addicted to
drugs do things to destroy yourself
because they hate you now watch The
Glory of
Christ Majestic don't let me send you
out here
please when he saw Jesus from afar he
ran and worshiped
him worshiped him the Greek word is
worship
Pro some translations will say bow down
no no no they were worshiping so not all
translations are equal let me show it to
you
Mark
56 let me get you the
link have you learned a lot today and a
lot about the depth of scripture and
the relationship between demons and
unsaved and and if you've been following
me this is not the first
time I've mentioned this over the years
because I've brought up this topic over
and over again but for some of you it
may be the first time
is this for the first time for some of
you well it shouldn't be because you
need solid churches and practice what do
they do
pro
pro what is
pro glad you asked worshiped him it
comes
from to worship to bow down prostrate
they were worshiping
him they were worshiping him now let me
ask you a
question this was the first time they
were seeing Jesus on Earth meaning this
is the first meeting these demons had
with Jesus can I ask you a question they
hadn't seen him prior to this event on
Earth on earth right how is it the demon
seeing Jesus for the first time already
knew who he
was that he's the son of the most high
and already knew he has the power to
torture them how would they know this
when they're seeing him for the first
time on Earth this is their first
Earthly encounter how would they know
this how did they know who he was and
how did they know that he has the power
to torment
them you know why because they remember
him from the Heavenly realm here's an
argument for Jesus's prehuman existence
even though this is the first time
they're seeing him on Earth this is not
the first time they had seen him they
know who he is from the Heavenly realm
they know who he is the son of God
who has been assigned to torment them on
the day they recognize him you know why
because demons see the inner person not
just the outward show the Bible is clear
that demons who are spirits look inside
the body and see the inner person that
spirit that soul that animates the body
so they saw beyond the Flesh and saw
this person who is in flesh that's the
Son of God who's been assigned to
destroy us on the
day that's how they knew